Like a boss. Somebody told me on a Twitter to watch this,
hang on a on Netflix, on green berets
before a man is trained to be a green moray.
He must prove he's cut out for the job.
This special forces assessment and selection
survive two weeks in hell and navy. They'll take you out.
You know if I rented the right one, there's a couple of them.
The one that I rented was a, I don't know, something.
11 weeks of hell or something to hang on a second.
Let me see if I can find this shit. Oh sorry. The 11 weeks, two weeks.
Do you know why I said 11 cause of the two L's in hell, I swear to God,
the way my brain works, this is the only fucking job I could ever do.
So there's a couple,
there's one national GRI of geographic special forces put over this two weeks in
hell.
I was watching this thing they just showed the first couple of fucking days.
I could tell you right now,
there's no fucking way I could ever be a green baret.
You'll lie to yourself having never been in the military that I could do that.
You know, I put my fucking head down no fucking way.
Go on Netflix and check that out. That's my youtube video of the week,
except it's on Netflix. Watch two weeks of hell.
I've only watched the first episode, Dude. It's just fucking insane.
The special forces assessment and selection process has officially started.
We've would a pit, there'll be no spitting in the pit, no puking.
Everyone expects to get their ass kicked.
The first day you're there, they have a thousand pound log that 12 guys grab
with 12 people to a log.
It's attempting not to carry your weight all the way up
and you're just sitting there bending over at the waist as you're holding it,
like you're going to do curls up, down, up, down, up, down, up,
down. Like my lower back would just, that would be it.
I would never walk right again.
And then they have it on your shoulder and you've got to pick it up over your
head and then down and they're sitting there going,
move the log around your head.
Not your head around the log,
you're not moving your head around a log door,
picking up the log and moving it around your head.
Number one 67 what is your problem? They fucking going off on him.
Yeah.
And uh, you do that for like a fucking hour.
Then they just have you rolling on the ground from one side of the pit to the
other. And if you too slow, other people rollover you.
Hello? Hey, if your body is weaker,
then you roll over half ways on hell,
no way on you.
And it's supposed to make you dizzy and disoriented.
And when you puke, you have to get up and run out of the pit.
There's no puking in the pit, but they know you're going to puke.
So you have to run out of the pit and Puke. If you puke in the pit,
you have to pick the puke up and put it in your pockets and then get back on the
ground and start rolling again.
They've got that week. What are your
[inaudible]
and even the people who are dropping like flies,
I got to commend them for even less than an hour. That shit, you got to see it.
All right. If you think you're working out doing your insanity workout,
go fuck yourself and watch this thick.
It's the sick I have now.
I'm just on the second episode where the just showing the teamwork. Oh my God,
do they have one thing there?
When you're your mill in North Carolina and they call this thing like the star,
this is the star land navigation test.
The distances, the dense terrain and the time pressure. Make it a killer.
Well you have these five points that make a star that you have to find using
navigation and you can't use your light and you can't go on the roads and you're
just walking through the fucking forest.
This is our chance to see their ability to comprehend and learn basic line
navigation skills with a simple map, a compass and a protractor.
And we want the guy that's gonna go out there and find all of his points no
matter what.
And when you come upon a river or a pond,
you have to walk through the fucking thing.
You can't go on a road and they bust all, you can't sleep.
They bust and they got these guys with these infrared goggles like Rambo hiding
and catching all of these guys when they cheat,
getting ready to go out,
down to a choke point where candidates like to get out onto the road,
get out of the woods and try to keep their feet dry. It's basically cheating.
Basically. I'm just going to be there and try to catch these guys in the act.
And then you're out of the fucking program.
Here's your region. There's one area, it's got tire tracks and it's wide,
which you just walked down. Let me see your scorecard candidate.
You have just become a roadkill, continue your point,
get off my road.
Um, it's just like,
I don't think I could go more than 18 seconds watching this thing without going.
I quit there. I'd quit there. I would fail that.
The only thing I thought I'd be halfway decent on is the a the obstacle course
because, uh, I do pull ups and climb a rope.
25 obstacles stretch over two miles
for candidates. Lacking upper body strength, balance
and coordination. This course is a killer.
But
even then I do pull ups and climb a rope after eight hours sleep.
And I had a nice bowl of oatmeal, you know,
my wife gives me a kiss on the cheek and then I go down there and I do is I go
and you know, I do as many as I can until it starts to hurt. That hurts.
And then I stopped.
Yeah.
Are you waiting on me? Whoa.
Are you glad you find me? Fucking baller.
Fucking treat the shit. Get the fuck off.
Get the fuck down off of the obstacle.
Oh, Jesus. I thought I was way closer to being in Greenbrae than I actually am.
I thought I was only, you know, 1 million miles away from it.
I didn't realize I was light years away. So, uh, anybody listened to this?
If you ever even attempted to become one if or if you are one or whatever you,
if you have any fucking personal stories that you could send in about attempting
that, uh, I don't know. The level of pain, whatever,
what it's like to scoop up puke and put it in any fucking pockets. I mean,
Jesus Christ, you know what's funny is those,
you know when you join a Frat, how they go, Hey,
they have hell week and all that type of shit.
Like anybody who's a Greenbrae should be an honorary member member of every
fraternity in the country because I know that those fucking,
what a why can't I remember how long it is? I want to say two weeks.
It is two weeks. I keep thinking 11 that right there dude,
look at that.
I am already fucked in the head before they actually deprived me of sleep.
They asked this one guy, they go, how long you been in here?
And he said Hash browns
number 90 has completely lost his bearings. So I know where you lost
and this is the thing, he didn't take a head shot.
It's not like a football player.
They just had him pick a log up for a fucking hour.
It'll roll around in the ground and they asked him,
they asked him something like that, like how you feeling? And he said,
hashbrowns so I dunno Jesus Christ.
If that doesn't make you want to watch it, I don't know what will
going through seven two ropes, k, they don't want their a three.
You need to see a medic one, three, seven they continue to train.
It's the most stressful part of selection. Instead of this,
your test within a test, you told me that you would start performing.
Let's just see. Go take your break.
Just see you. One six seven let's just see the
number one 67 what is your problem?